les enquêteurs russes ont confirmé que
l'airbus a321 s'est brisé en plein vol à
9000 mètres d'altitude ce qui fait que
les débris se sont répandus sur une
vaste superficie 20 kilomètres carrés
dans le sinaï égyptien et représentants
de la compagnie aérienne connue sous
deux noms khogali mavia ou métro jet
rejette toute idée que l'écrasement soit
dû à une défaillance technique ou à une
erreur humaine selon la compagnie seules
une intervention extérieure une action
technique ou physique a pu causer la
dislocation soudaine de l'avion équipage
c'est la seule explication plausible
selon alexander smirnov directeur
général adjoint de la compagnie les
pilotes n'ont même pas pu réagir et
envoyé ne serait ce qu'un seul appel de
détresse
en egypte un enquêteur qui a eu accès
aux boîtes noires de l'avion confirmé
sous couvert de l'anonymat qu'il n'y
avait pas eu de signal de détresse de
l'équipage
il affirmait que l'avion n'a pas été
frappé de l'extérieur on mettra des
semaines à analyser à fond le contenu de
ces boîtes noires
ce tome à moscou le président vladimir
poutine de mardi aux enquêteurs de
dresser un portrait objectifs de ce qui
s'est vraiment passé
interrogé sur la possibilité qu'il
s'agisse d'un acte terroriste de porte
parole du président répondait qu'on a
éliminé aucune hypothèse
ils mettaient en garde contre toute
conclusion hâtive
une branche du groupe armé état
islamique prétend avoir abattu l'avion
mais rien n'indique qu'il a les moyens
d'atteindre une telle cible qui volent à
9000 mètres d'altitude
la majorité des corps des victimes de
l'écrasement ont été rapatriés par avion
à saint pétersbourg
là même où il aurait dû atterrir samedi
de retour de sharm el sheikh et si
raymond st-pierre radio canada à moscou